Bruce is on Facebook what's your opinion
on settling old debts for less than what
is owed well the only reason you would
do that is if you do not have the money
to pay what is owed let's start with the
moral principle the moral is moral thing
to do is if you owe money and you have
the money to pay the bill that you have
you should simply pay it so you owe a
thousand dollars on a bill from five
years ago
and now you have a thousand dollars you
should simply pay the bill but let's say
that you have tens of thousands of
dollars of old debt and you're just
digging your way out and you don't have
any money today but you save up a
thousand dollars you owe tens of
thousands and you offer that thousand
dollars to someone that you owe three
thousand dollars to and they decide to
accept it because it's been five years
since they've got any money and you say
I got a thousand dollars today if you
want that we'll settle it if you don't
want that we won't settle it and they
decide to accept it then what that is is
a you had a contract a handshake if you
will for three thousand dollars the
contract went bad and now you're making
an offer to change the contract if the
party that is owed the money says no I
want my three thousand dollars well you
own three thousand dollars you legally
will have to pay them morally we'll have
to pay them but if they say no it's been
a long time then I'll take a bird in the
hand rather than sixteen promises from
you I'll take my thousand dollars and
run I'll take a thousand bucks for the
three thousand dollar debt then get that
in writing and no electronic access to
your checking account they don't have
access to your money you get it in
writing from them and there's no moral
breakdown on settling that debt but if
you're sitting on ten thousand dollars
in you owe a thousand and you call and
settle that debt there's a moral
breakdown there I wouldn't do that you
owe the money you should pay the bill
that you owe
and by the way that verse is what we've
exactly said for 25 and a half years
here on the air that has never changed
one time now I get calls where I never
talk about parts of that discussion or I
just say this is how you settle the debt
but in talking to the person I'm I'm
finding out that the person is broke so
I need to have a big moral discussion
with them they're broke there are no
money and so you get what you can get
you know I mean I got a guy that was me
forty thousand bucks that didn't pay me
fifteen years ago if he calls me up
today and says I'll give you $4,000 for
that forty thousand dollar debt that I
owe you would you settle it I would say
yeah because I don't think I'm ever
gonna see any of that money ever and I'd
be happy to get anything out of that guy
and I'd be happy I would be blessed I
would be $4,000 off to the good cuz I
will never see the 40 in my lifetime
that guy's not gonna call up and pay his
bill it's not gonna happen and he's not
gonna call up more for the four either
by the way but a point being I'm on the
other side of the equation here if I'm
the creditor if you're the creditor and
you haven't been paid in six months and
you don't think you're going to get paid
and somebody offers you will you take
what you can get and you say I made a
bad deal shouldn't I shouldn't have made
the deal with that guy and because he
can't manage money or he's bad or
whatever but for whatever reason or
another you're agreeing to accept it so
I do not as a philosophical thing an
integrity thing say that if you settle a
debt you have done something wrong
automatically
matter of fact you should offer to
settle debts and try to clean them and
to try to do something by the debt that
you owe
and by the way legally that helps you by
the way financially that helps you by
the way it actually helps your credit
because all that bad debt out there
hanging on your credit is going to
destroy it continually until it's paid
and it does not really go away I know
after seven years they're supposed to
drop off and it does most of the time
but sometimes they reissue that reset it
and man it here we go again and it's
just it's your 7 years to start over
it's not supposed to but believe me I've
run into stuff that was 14 15 years old
still showing up on a credit bureau
and so this idea that you're somehow
going to get away from it is just not
you know by not paying it it's not the
right thing so go settle it go do
something with the debt do the best you
can do with the money that you have and
make it go as far as you can go but um
sometimes I get people who are Pharisees
who are like everybody ought to pay a
hundred percent every time or you're
going to hell you know I mean these
people get all torqued out these are
people who have never been broke number
one and they're probably people who've
never been on the other side of not
getting paid like I've not gotten paid
people owe me is what I'm saying and I'm
happy to take a little off the top to
get some money out of them be happy to
settle that with them if I could get
something I've done that before now
don't relish the idea to rather just get
the money that's owed to me but if the
guys broke and I believe he's broke and
he's offering me a settlement hey he
said at least standing here you know hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you